Thanks to Brilliant for supporting this episode
of Journey to the Microcosmos.
Go to Brilliant.org/microcosmos to learn how
you can take your STEM skills to the next level!
It’s often said that one person’s trash
is another person’s treasure.
And surely there is no greater proof of that
than the home of our master of microscopes,
James.
All along the windowsills and bookshelves
are jars and tanks full of samples gathered
from ponds, lakes, and oceans.
And even his cabinets and drawers and bathroom
hold stockpiles of what he has found.
To someone who may not know any better, James’
house probably seems messy.
Very, very messy.
But we know better.
We know that his unusual decor is a testament
to his dedication to exploring the microcosmos,
countless little worlds that James has collected
and taken care of.
And most importantly, James doesn’t have
a problem sharing space with his samples.
Scratch that.
There actually is one problem...
The snails.
Whenever James brings home his latest collection,
his goal is to be able to watch the organisms
inside for a very long time.
That’s why he takes such care to give them
the sun and water and nutrition that each
tiny little world needs so that he can watch
the populations of algae and hydra
and so much more grow.
But aquatic snails are the slow-moving Godzillas
of these worlds, dining on just about anything
that is in their path.
They chomp away at the unfortunate creatures
that get in their way,
leaving a path of destruction in their wake.
And worse, they reproduce like bunny rabbits.
So with very little effort, a small snail
problem can become a very big snail problem,
a landscape overrun with a creature that simply
does not care about the human whose treasure
it’s devouring into trash.
So a sight like this one should be a crisis
for a master of microscopes.
Aquatic snails lay their eggs in a gelatinous
mass, which can hold hundreds of little guys
like these squirming in their developing bodies
and shells.
Depending on the species, you might find these
sacks of eggs floating in water or stuck to plants.
Or, maybe even on the wall of an aquarium.
But as terrifying as the prospect of a future
filled with hundreds of new snails ready to
eat up all of James’ samples is, even he
has to admit that…these are kind of adorable.
They’re both squishy and iridescent, an
uncommon pairing made all the cuter with their
beady little eyes.
The snail eggs that James finds usually develop
pretty fast, sometimes hatching within a few
days of when he stumbles upon them.
But this time he was lucky, he was able to
catch them right before they hatched so the
embryos were fully visible.
But while they might be adorable now, they
won’t stay that way.
They will grow quickly, the small pearly iridescent
shell building into the larger encasements
that house mature snails.
But let’s be upfront about something.
There are thousands and thousands of species
of snail, and we at Journey to the Microcosmos
don’t know enough to be able to identify
exactly what species we’re looking at.
So we’re speaking very generally today.
Snails are members of the Mollusca phylum,
which includes oysters, clams, octopuses, and squids.
And while not all of those creatures make
shells, the ones that do build primarily with
calcium carbonate, a hard mineral that protects
the softer animal within.
As we’ve seen, the building of those shells
begins before the snails are even born.
And those shells will remain with the
snail until they die.
As an embryo, the snail grows a protoconch,
which will lay a sort of foundation for the future shell.
And after hatching, construction continues
as an organ called the mantle begins to secrete
layers of calcium carbonate that then crystallize.
As more layers are added, the shell’s characteristic
spiral begins to take shape.
Interestingly, snail shells almost always
spiral clockwise.
But they can, on rare occasions, produce a
counter-clockwise spiral, a mutation that
researchers were able to trace to a single gene.
And if the shell is broken during the snail’s
lifetime, it can produce more calcium carbonate
through its mantle to seal up the cracks.
It’s clear though from the different patterns
and colors we can see on these shells that
there’s more to shell-building than just
calcium carbonate.
The outside of the shells are encased in a
layer called periostracum, made up of proteins,
carbohydrates, fats…and pigments that will
eventually come to define the snail’s appearance.
Shells may be a snail’s most obvious feature,
but there are plenty of other fascinating
things to see as well.
Like these grains wiggling around inside a
recently deceased snail.
The organ that holds them is called a statocyst,
and it helps the snail understand just how
its body is situated in the space around them.
As the snail moves, the grains—or statoliths—bump
up against the walls of the statocyst, brushing
against little sensory hairs that send information
to the snail’s nervous system so it can
process its shifting position.
And that strange texture you see in the middle
of the screen, which looks like a weird footprint
that’s actually a dead snail’s tongue, or more
accurately, its radula.
Radulas are a structure particular to mollusks.
And while we originally called it a tongue,
it’s perhaps more appropriate to refer to
the radula as a membrane covered in rows and
rows of teeth that works with the snail’s flexible jaw.
As the snail moves, it can use its radula
to scrape up algae or cut up plants.
Which means that this weird membrane full
of teeth, this wondrous utensil that helps
the snail eat as it slowly ambles along the
world—this is James’ enemy.
This is the nozzle attached to the unwelcome
vacuum cleaner that digests and clears up
the jars and tanks that he does not want to
be cleared.
But as we said: one person’s trash.
Another person’s treasure.
There are many aquarium owners who seek
out snails precisely because they will clear
out algae and other small organisms or waste
that take over their tank.
Snails serve an important ecological function
in these cases, maintaining an environment
that supports the growth of
other good organisms.
So, as the old saying goes, one person’s
slow moving Godzilla is another’s fish tank
vacuum cleaner.
Thank you for coming on this journey with
us as we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
And thank you to Brilliant for sponsoring
this episode.
Brilliant features hands-on, interactive courses
in science, engineering, computer science and math.
And Brilliant has recently increased the interactivity
in their courses.
In their Scientific Thinking course, you’ll
dive into the world of scientific principles
by exploring the laws of physics and principles
of engineering.
Along the way you’ll gain the understanding
and insight needed to start looking at the
world in a different way.
The courses are designed for people of all
levels, so you can jump in at any point and
work your way to mastery.
And Brilliant courses are also available offline
using their iOS and Android app.
So if you’re traveling or have a spotty
internet connection, you’ll be able to keep learning.
If you’re interested in learning more, you
can get 20% off an annual premium subscription
at Brilliant.org/microcosmos.
The people’s whose names are on the screen
right now, they are our Patreon patrons.
They’re the people who make it possible
for us to continue sharing with you the magesties
of this tiny tiny world that is absolutely
everywhere.
I’m not saying that James wouldn’t have
an apartment full of algae jars if it weren’t
for you, but your support does make it easier
to explain that to visitors.
And if you’re interested in joining these people,
you can check out our Patreon at
Patreon.com/JounryToMicro.
If you’d like to see more from our Master
of Microscopes James Weiss, you can check
out Jam & Germs on Instagram.
And if you want to see more from us, there’s
probably a subscribe button somewhere nearby.